[Music]
what you got here it's Habitat who's a
habitat for a baby de sleeps over here
beside the rocks to keep it safe from
Hunters smart
[Music]
dear Helena Ericson what are you doing
with my house what's going on your
father Jacob Holbrook when was the last
time you spoke to him when I was 10
years old I'm confused I thought your
parents died in a car accident that's
what I told
you H Brook he's the marshing guy I
heard about on the radio he and another
prisoner escaped last
night Jacob Holbrook the so-called Marsh
King abducted Beth Ericson and held her
for 12 years in the wilderness with the
daughter she gave birth to while in
captivity hope I'm not trespassing or
anything we have to go
please stop father
I think he's coming for
[Music]
me I wish he would have told me the
truth he gave me this after my first
kill these were the only tears my father
ever wanted to see you'll always be my
little Shadow now I realized the person
I believed in the most was really a
monster this means her
family it means owned not family don't
confuse the
two
what's going on in Elena I feel like
he's here
Miracle has that been in your room the
whole time
mhm you must always protect your
[Music]
family oh God Helena it's
me this is where we
belong I wait up my home whole life to
see you again I wasn't sure what I would
feel when I
[Music]
did we can still all be a
family